well if you liked Photoshop you should
just keep going with you know learning
to use premier and then there are many
modeling programs and animation and it's
analysts as I'm sure you can imagine but
you know just the mastery of tools I
mean we all have this idea that we
shouldn't learn anything after the age
of 30 or something like that I don't
think you can live like that anymore I
mean I could spend if somebody would pay
me I could spend all my time learning
software learning to do things better
and to bring more control to to my art
you know and the software is endlessly
evolving too I mean everything is if it
seems to be evolving together I think
yeah I mean I think you know you can
never the future is always more
complicated than any ideological agenda
imagine soup so you know right at this
moment even as we're reaching toward
virtual reality and immortality and
whatnot there are people Scarah fiying
themselves in the rainforest tonight and
eating the the log drums and you know
nothing has changed so yeah it's really
about stretching out over a broader and
broader spectrum I have no problem with
the people scarifying themselves in the
rainforest I'm all for that what I don't
like is the Bulge in the middle of the
snake where millions and millions of
people are narcotic those cells on mall
culture and television I mean I'm not
gonna launch a moral crusade to take
away people's daytime TV watching but I
certainly think well
well that the basic thing is to build
the tools and then the smart people will
use those tools to push the the edge of
novelty for with them who are the smart
people it's not all but it's well no
it's not an elite of class or an elite
of money although both of those things
play into it it's an it's an elite of
technological intelligence you know
there will be people in the slums of
Shanghai who will be world leaders in
this field simply out of their tenacious
intelligence that wonderful thing Gibson
says in Neuromancer the street finds its
own uses for things so in a way it's the
confounding of all other of the other
forms of hierarchy in other words clasps
in based institutions money based
institutions race based institutions are
all having a very difficult time keeping
up with what's going on it seems it's
more like a kind of an artistic or
chaotic situation where very creative
individuals can move very fast
you know cyberspace is a land of
opportunity we see example after example
of this
[Music]